les inégalités économiques augmentent
elles en france ça c'est la grosse
question inégalités économiques en
france
effectivement progresse peut être moins
vite qu'ailleurs mais elle progresse
quand même parce que 1 aujourd'hui on
voit que l'impôt sur le revenu c'est un
impôt qui fonctionne moins bien et
qu'aujourd'hui ce sont les impôts qui
sont proportionnelles type tva csg qui
rapporte plus à l'état que l'impôt
progressif donc un outil essentiel de
réduction des inégalités est grippé
deuxièmement pour des catégories de
salariés
la progression des salaires reste très
lente 1 parce que quand ce sont des
salariés peu qualifiés
ils ont une pression qui vient la mise
en concurrence que la mondialisation
organise troisièmement aujourd'hui nous
vivons une époque que le travail et
surtout les ménages supportent plus la
charge est prêt non obligatoire que les
entreprises et en plus on est dans un
contexte européen qui ne favorise pas la
réduction des inégalités parce que au
niveau européen s'organise aussi une
concurrence sociale et fiscale qui est
assez terrible et que la compétitivité
devenu le maître mot politique et pour
certains salariés sur tous les salariés
soient issus des catégories ouvrières
n'employer et bien voient leur situation
se dégrader on parle même aujourd'hui en
france une baisse pour certaines
catégories du niveau trip aujourd'hui si
vous voulez en france
ce qui permet d'amortir cette
progression des inégalités
c'est le rôle de distributeur de l'état
social et s'il n'y a pas cet amortisseur
qui permet effectivement de faire en
sorte qu'on a tout pauvreté plus faible
que nos partenaires allemands par
exemple eh bien on a en france une
logique inégalitaire qui s'est mise en
place et les mesures de fiscalité
récentes apportées par le gouvernement
philippe et bien va dans ce sens
c'est à dire dans un sens où ce sont les
plus hauts de la distribution qui
récupère davantage de revenus
l'étude récente de l'eau fce le montrer
des études de l'insee également
[Musique]